[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis my friends this
is guns in here
welcome to the 26th episode of dirty
chest tricks in this episode I'm going
to show you some of the wonderful tricks
in the x-rated London system from the Y
perspective
we are starting with the main line which
arises after the more water D phone defy
push-up to a floor Knight to f6 Knight
to f3 c phi III Knight to c6 c3 e 6
Knight B to d2 and now Bishop to d6 so
this position can be reached by a
different model and this is one of the
most popular response from the black
perspective here there are two moves
exist but first I like to continue with
the main line move that is Bishop to g3
and after black castle and white plays
Bishop to d3 black has two popular
choice in this position first let's
consider Queen to e7 well after that I
should continue with the move Knight to
e5 and more often here black continue
with the move Knight to d7 try to get
rid of this centralized knight in this
position f4 is most frequently played
responds by wide but instead of that I'm
going to recommend a very tricky move
that is Knight capacity 7 and trick is
set right here black has 2 choices but
amongst them Bishop captures d7 looks
very natural but in fact it turns out
that this move leads to the instant
disaster let's see how so here white
first of all take this Bishop after
Queen takes White will take under the
pawn and after Queen takes white give
black this ultimate shocked Bishop
captures at 7 boom
well black response is forced black
cannot play King to h8 due to the move
Queen to h5 so that's why King captures
at 7 is force but after that White will
give this track and after King to g8
White has planned this amazing shot
Knight to e4 attacking the Queen and
that Knight is eager to go to the gfs
where I got two games in this position
in the first game
my opponent try the moon g6 so
counter-attacking my queen but after a
night captures pawn captures Knight
captures d7 attacking the rook rook to
d8 but then Knight to f6 Jack regain one
more porn with White has a clear
two-point advantage so it's very obvious
that here black has to move the Queen
and after the move Queen to b6 white
obviously play Knight to g5 and there's
a checkmate rate on that 7 square here
it is very obvious that black has to
move the rook to safeguard the mate so
rook to e8 looks very obvious but then
white has this sequence that is Queen
check King to a change and now simple
but very effective castle on the Kings
side and even though materially white is
down black position is completely losing
now just to illustrate my point in the
game my opponent who is 2100 rated he
continued with the move Knight to e7 I
responded with the move f4 and you can
see the easiest but very effective plant
by the white what white wants to do is
he wants to play rook to f3 rook to s3
and checkmate blacking even though white
is allowing this check but after that
black is completely hopeless to stop our
plan after a long thought my opponent
come up with the move Knight to a5 but
it's not going to stop anything because
rook to f3 comes anyways and in the game
he has to give up his queen but we
should see that what happens if Queen
tried to run away let's say Queen to d2
then we have rook check and after night
red six rook takes at 6 pawn takes and
Queen to at 7 is a checkmate so this is
a very tricky idea by white which
recently comes into the limelight which
completely stopped Bishop to d7 idea
well you may ask what happens if Queen
catches v7 we're here my recommendation
is if you playing with a load seated up
on and then you should capture the c5
pawn and continue with your game but if
you are playing with a higher seeded up
on end then this is even better because
you can get as force draw after the
following sequence that is Bishop
captures Queen captures pawn captures
Queen captures and the same motifs yup
Bishop captures at 7 after King takes
Queen check King to g8 and Knight to e4
if Queen to b6 then pretty much we have
the same story but here black has the
only saving grace sauce that is g6 and
you can see the big time difference over
here that black Bishop is not on d7 and
that's why this counter is very
effective nevertheless white should
continue with the move Queen to g5 and
after Queen to e7 and Knight we have six
check we have a force perpetual which
leads to the draw
okay let's consider the second mu that
is b6 which in fact the highest played
move in this position but against it I'm
going to recommend a very tricky more
order starting with the move Knight to
e5 now here if your opponent doesn't
take this night and continued his piece
development such as Bishop to b7 then I
think after f4 might get an upgrade
version of the stonewall where this
ducks will Bishop is not sitting on c1
but it is actively participating in the
game while the MU H fire so that's why
at this position many black player try
to get rid of this night as soon as
possible
with the move Bishop captures ePHI okay
white should continue with the MU D
captures ePHI attacking the nigh and
after Knight to d7 f4 is the most common
reply over here but we are playing for
the tricks and that's why I'm going to
show you a very tricky move in this
position that is might we have three
defending the FI square at first sight
it looks like this is not good the
simple reason is after Queen to c7 that
pawn is a goner yes indeed but White has
a better idea and that is bam ha-ha-ha
okay black has two options if King to
etch it then Knight to g5 anyways so
White has a clear-cut idea of Queen to
h5 so black needs to stop it with the
moon g6 but then the following
continuation happens that is the ship
captures pawn captures Knight captures
c6 attacking two spots Queen to b7 and
after Knight takes Knight takes and
Queen captures defy white obtained rook
and a4 pawn for the two minor pieces
which is almost a decisive advantage so
it's very obvious here that black has to
capture this bishop but after that we
are going to continue with the Moon
Knight check tally note if King to g8
Queen to h5 is a very deadly reply so
the only good move over here is King to
g6 after that fight will continue with
Queen to c2 Jack
now if the King goes to the s6 or the H
file square then after Queen - at 7 it
is more or less checkmate scenario so
black has to play other moose and it's
very important to understand that King
cannot take this 9 the simple reason is
after Bishop to a4 check King to g4 f3
King to h4 and Queen - at 7 is a good
night sweet dream for the black king so
the only move to keep black in the game
is Fi blocking the diagonal but then
white has this very simple move he kept
his f6 discover check - the black king
and same time hitting the Queen and
after the following continuation that is
King kept us up 6 night check
King b7 and Bishop captures c7 why it
has a huge advantage
now if you really want to trick your
opponent especially in the official two
domains then the following trick is very
useful because it's not a very common
setup by wide and there are every chance
that you can finish your opponent very
quickly trick start with unusual move
Bishop captures 86 after Queen captures
d6 white should continue with the move
Bishop to b5 now doesn't matter whether
your opponent plays Bishop to d7 or
Castle let's say in this game black
continue with the castle on the Kings
side and white did the same and after
the move Bishop to d7 white should
continue with the move here for well
it's very natural that black is going to
keep this Bishop with the move asics
and after the move Bishop to e2 you can
see that black has an enough protection
to play the movie Phi and liberate his
position and that's why even at the
highest level I have seen this mood
played by the black player but can you
believe Black has made a blunder yes
indeed before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out what is
the repetition okay I hope you find this
wonderful move Knight to c4
hahaha well sacrificing the whole piece
and black has to accept it
otherwise the e5 point will be a goner
and after the move D kept C for white
reveal his nasty idea he kept c5
attacking to piece black responds his
force
black has to exchange the Queen but even
after the Queen exchanged black is not
out of the wood because white is still
attacking two spots the most logical
response over here is Bishop to b6 but
then white can take this piece and the
following order will highlight not only
white get an extra pawn but black
position will be completely shattered
here I should continue with the moon I
to D to connote B Phi or Knight to e5
doesn't matter
let's say in this game black plays
Knight to e5 to defend his pawn and now
white plays the move Knight to e4
hitting two spots which cannot be
defended let's fast forward a few moves
Knight to b3 Knight f6 Jack King to g7
Knight to H Phi Jack and after King 2 at
6 and rook to be running not only white
emerge with an extra pawn but black pawn
structures are completely ruined
the second setup I want to consider is
when black plays this oddly c phi mu
well here black has to be very careful
as immediate Queen to b6 it's not a good
move the simple reason is white can play
the move Knight to c3 and now black
can't even take this form because after
Knight to defy this is almost a losing
position in the opening so this is a
perfect beginner trap which many below
1600 players fall into black's idea is
not to play Queen to b6 but to play in 9
to c6 and after white response with the
move c3 black continue with his
energetic style with the move Queen to
b6 so because now white cannot play
Knight to c3 Queen to b6 does make a lot
of sense well here why should continue
with the move Queen to b3 and both the
sides are hoping that other side will
take his queen and in that case the a
file will open up here the obvious
response from the black is to play c4
provoking the Queen exchange and why
should certainly doesn't capture that
Queen and instead of that what should
continue with the move Queen to c2 and
here comes one of the most amazing trick
because at first sight it looks like
black can hit this Queen with the move
Bishop to a5 and White Queen cannot take
this bishop as the B to pawn will fall
and surprisingly enough even one title
player has try against me but I think
this is outright blunder black should
play this Bishop f5 move where his
Knight is already on f6 square there's a
reason why this is not possible because
white can simply took this Bishop and
challenged black into the complications
Queen captures b2 what else and white
took the d5 pawn now if black plays
Queen to Steven check then white can
continue with the MU King to e2 and this
line is even better for the white and I
have attached sample line in the PGN
which is available in description so
kindly go through it the main move
here is Queen captures rook which looks
very obvious but then wide reveal his
cunning idea with the move Queen to be
fire so not only defending the knight
but attacking on b7 the most logical
response is castle on the Queen side and
now you play Bishop capture c4 and now
white is all set to trap that baby in
the corner
well it sounds strange but yup
white is just three moves away to
capturing that Queen the best response
goes as follows
black plays Aoife attacking the bishop
here white more or less doesn't care
about that piece he just want to get
that Queen so white has to play Knight
to e2 and after pawn captures Bishop why
should castle on the Kings side and now
indeed Knight to d2 is on the card and
how the health black in will escape
black and play this counter attacking
move Essex but then Queen check came to
b8 and Queen to c2 confirms that Queen
is going to be lost so after few moves
let's say pawn captures pawn captures
Knight to f6 Knight to d2 Queen captures
rook Knight captures Queen and we have a
situation where white obtained queen and
a pawn for the two rooks so in terms of
material it looks a balanced position
but the major factor is this central
pawn are really cramping all the minor
pieces now just to demonstrate how
dangerous this position is for the black
I like to show you one of my game
against national master where he played
rook to d7 defending the f7 I continue
with the movie for which prevent
national development of that Bishop so
my opponent decided to play Bishop to e7
and I continue with my pawn roll ePHI I
think the night he continued with the
move Knight to g4 I played Queen to e4
hitting denied he defended with the move
H file and now ash-tree
night to at 6 and
now comes the very simple tactic
pressure capture z6 my upper and
desperately looking for the counter play
so he responded with the move Epps --ax
hitting my pawn Center I responded with
the move Bishop to b5 and after pawn
capture us
I played night to e3 so you can already
see Black is in a big difficult
situation he continued with the move he
catches d4 but it turns out that this
move is a big mistake because after
Knight captures d4 not only that night
vanished from the game but this night
check proves very deadly as after King
to c7 and Knight captures Issa well
white emerged with a great material
advantage
third response I want to consider his
nimza or Queen's Indian setup which
arises after the Mordor
Knight to f6 and after Bishop to f4
black responds with the movie six blacks
idea is after the move Knight to f3 he
wants to play Utley C Phi and after we
play III he wants to continue with the
move b6 so Bishop obviously go to the b7
square where combined with the f6 Knight
it controls the e4 square now just
against this setup I'm going to
recommend a very tricky more durable
white let's start with the move Knight B
to d2 and after the move Bishop to b7
you should immediately put this knight
on the C 4 square so you can already see
two pieces are lining on the d6 square
and if allowed then white will certainly
nab a bishop pair with a very good
advantage so obviously you open it is
not going to allow this and they are
going to play D 6 or the D Phi move
where in either case white obtained a
winning position just only in the
opening ok let's see each bite on first
more I want to consider is d6 which on
the surface looks so natural but this is
a blunder move the simple reason is
after the pawn captures C Phi white 3
pcs are attacking on d6 so black cannot
capture with the beep own and if he
captured with the D pawn then the
situation is even worst because after
Queen captures King captures Knight to
g5 hitting the f7 and after King to aid
White has this star mu Knight to e5 and
now there is no way black and save this
epsilon
last but not least what happens if you
open in place defy well my response is
very obvious but is going to play in
Knight to e5 and now White has two
threats which I don't think black and
defend both of them now as I have
alleged over here there are three ways
black and try to stop these threats but
none of them succeed first more I want
to consider is Knight B to d7 it's
dropping Knight to g5 idea but here
white has this another thread that is
Bishop to b5
pinning denied and now indeed renewing
the threat of 925 I reached this
position in one of my game where my
opponent attack my bishop with the move
a six but then comes Knight to g5
anyways after black captured my piece I
responded with the Moon Knight captures
f7 and after Queen to e7 and Knight
captures sashayed if allowed the night
will come back into the life via app 7
to d6 root so my opponent played a six
but he completely missed that night can
go with the other rule that is white to
g6 attacking the Queen Queen to d8
Knight captures c6 attacking the Queen
Queen to see aid and now they're dancing
Knight captured another piece with the
move Knight captures a fade and it's
very funny that black cannot even touch
that piece because after Knight captures
White has this little check
Knight to c7 and black is going to lose
another exchanger okay what happens if
you open in place another Knight move
that is night F to d7 well here white
Mordor will remain same white is going
to pin that night and now we already
know that if you open and place a six we
can continue with the move Knight to g5
but here black has this cunning idea
epps six hitting this night well this
time around white can sacrifice another
piece because black has weakened his
King side
and here I'm proposing why should
continue with the move Knight which file
after pawn captures and Queen check
Callie node g6 is not possible because
of the night captures e6 so black has to
forcefully play King to e7 afterwards
white has this simple but very effective
move D captures efile so the threat is
very obvious Bishop to g5 and
surprisingly enough check can't do
anything about it the base black and
clay over here is Knight to c6
but after Bishop to g5 Knight to f6 pawn
captures pawn captures and Knight to g6
it is very clear that what is going to
get an exchange
you may be wondering hang on that Bishop
is hanging right yes indeed but after
pawn captures White has this screen
check which regain his piece and with
extra exchange White will have an easy
game last but not least what happens if
you open in place the move head 6 well
it stopped one thread but it doesn't do
anything with the move Bishop to b5
check and now however black blocks he
get worse position so for example Knight
f2 d7 can be met by Knight captures d7
and after Knight captures d7 where I can
play the Moon Knight me fire so hitting
the knight twice the only good way to
defend this is Bishop to c8 but then
white has this very tricky move Queen to
f3 which believe it or not gives white
of winning advantage just to give you
some sample lines if you open in place
Bishop to d6 which at first sight looks
very natural because he wants to get rid
of this pesky knife but then comes
Bishop captures d7 check and after
Bishop captures v7y it has this lethal
blow Bishop to g5 BAM queeny's attack
and as a maid threatened and if black
tried to save both the things with the
more Epps --ax then he can pack his bag
and go home
the
cause we are going to checkmate him with
the Queen Jack King to e7 and now
finishing knot Queen to have seven in
the situation the best move is Queen to
f6
but even though this doesn't stop by to
gain his extra advantage because after
Bishop to c6 hitting the rook and after
rook to b8 White has this lethal move
Knight to g4 attacking Queen attacking
the rook and black position is
completely collapsing that's it guys I
hope you enjoy and learn this wonderful
tricks in the excited London system
I am personally using the system as my
secret weapon and so far I have beat
many 2,000 plus rated player with this
tricks in all formats of the game the
good point about this tricks are even
though if you open doesn't fall for it
you still obtain a very good position
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care
thank you and congratulations once again
we can invite the winners of the Blitz
okay so let's see what's wrong with the
move Asics after all its initial move
it's kicking the night and what can be
the bed well here comes our shock weapon
with the move Bishop to b6 spam